Marvel fans, I am here
with Zendaya, MJ herself.
How are you?
I'm good, how are you?
I'm doing pretty great.
So I have a couple of questions.
Yes.
This is the biggest
Spider-Man film yet
and there's a lot of stunts.
Yes.
How did it feel to be
web-slinging and flying high?
Oh man, it was so much fun.
I loved being able
to do that stuff,
especially because we
feel incredibly safe.
We have an amazing
stunt coordinator
and you just get to have fun.
I'm not afraid of
heights in that way
so I feel really good about it.
Yeah well I can't wait to see.
How has MJ changed since
we've last seen her?
I think she's just
opening up more.
I think now that she has Peter
in her life, and someone--
and Ned obviously-- people
who feel that-- love her
for who she is, I think
she's able to slightly
just open up a little bit more.
And maybe even be a
little bit more positive,
because usually she's like
the nihilistic friend, right?
She's the one that's
always looking
at things glass
half empty, so it's
nice to see that side of her.
[MUSIC PLAYING]